Marvel's midnight Sun's story draws
clear Inspirations from the original
rise of the midnight Sun's comic book
series from the 1990s in which blade
morbius and Ghost Rider among others
unites to fight against a recently
resurrected Lilith and her Army of
demons developer frax's game's title
however incorporates more faces from the
current Midnight Sun series such as
Wolverine magic and Nico minoru in
making these changes it distances itself
from The Source material's idea that to
defeat a monster you need a team of
monsters it is a story about the power
of friendship between a bunch of Misfits
which is forged and strengthened through
battle as much as traditional social
scenarios midnight Suns aims to combine
relationship building with memorable
role-playing moments and the result is a
stellar turn-based tactical combat title
driven by interesting characters
Marvel's midnight Sons begins with the
Avengers in a tough spot the prophesized
return of an Eldritch God is on the
horizon having been brought about by
Lilith who now leads an army of Hydra
soldiers and demonic children in a war
against humanity The Avengers aren't
adequately prepared to tackle such a
supernatural threat so they turn to
doctor strange and his newest Apprentice
Scarlet witch for Aid after their first
attempt at fighting Lilith goes sideways
strange introduces the world's Mightiest
Heroes to the contingency plan the
midnight Sons a group of young Heroes
who each wield magical Supernatural or
demonic Powers that's where your
character the hunter comes in as the
child of Lilith you possess incredible
magical abilities which is what helped
you defeat her 300 years ago that Final
Duel left both you and Lilith dead but
just as Hydra managed to bring your
mother back to life the midnight sons
are able to do the same for you not
content to leave the fate of the world
up to the others The Avengers also
decide to set up shop in the midnight
Sun's headquarters The Abbey to join the
fight against Lilith the major conflict
in Marvel's midnight Suns is explored
through the tried and true formula of
what happens when the Old Guard meets
the new kids in Marvel's midnight Suns
The Avengers have already overcome the
likes of Ultron Galactus Thanos and
other would-be apocalypses so they're
not particularly eager to get input from
a newly formed team of much younger
Heroes and the midnight Sons believe the
Avengers are a bloated waste of space
for the mission at hand as the older
team is ill-prepared to tackle a magical
threat with the science they've relied
on for decades Marvel's midnight Sons
doesn't do anything new with this kind
of storyline but it does create plenty
of interesting moments throughout its 45
hour run time heroes like Iron Man and
Captain America find solace in their
struggles with their figurative demons
from the perspectives of those who have
dealt with literal ones or their lives
what does it look like when Tony Stark
who's fully cognized innocent of his
alcoholism and believes he's come to
terms with all the bad Life Choices he's
made through the good he's accomplished
as Iron Man meets Robbie Reyes a
Ghostwriter directly impacted by the
sins of Stark Industries that Tony has
willfully ignored these are the types of
questions that Marvel's midnight sons
asks and answers and the storylines are
regularly intriguing if a little
straightforward more enjoyable
complexity is found in the combat
missions the team embarks on to fight
against Lilith and her Army each mission
is structured around a turn-based
tactical combat system in which you
guide the positioning attacks and
defenses of your characters before the
enemy has a go at you and then you
respond in turn frax's games work on the
XCOM series is strongly represented here
with Marvel's midnight Sons trading in
soldiers and aliens for superheroes and
demons however it's not exactly a
one-to-one replication unlike x-com
character attacks and abilities always
hit their Mark there's no way for an
enemy to lower the chance of you hitting
them this ensures that the superheroes
you're playing as always feel as
powerful as they are depicted in other
media and that within the scope of a
single turn your actions will play out
as you intend removing xcom's
frustrating percentage system which
could cause even the most well-planned
strategies to inexplicably fail makes
the turn-based Tactical combat in
Marvel's midnight Suns a lot more fun
it's rewarding to see a plan come
together as intended in its place is a
deck building card system ensuring that
even if each individual turn plays out
as you planned you don't know what
you'll be able to do on your next turn
until it begins and you draw your hand
in this way there's still an element of
challenging Randomness to every
encounter encouraging you to think
strategically through every Mission but
it's being used to test your ability to
think and plan on the Fly that is way
better than having to trust in an unseen
dice roll that may screw you over and
see you somehow miss shooting a bad guy
who's two feet away because the
percentage was only 98 and you just got
unlucky then is one exception to the use
of unseen dice rolls and that's knocking
enemies off the map whether it's over
the side of a skyscraper or into one of
Ghost Rider's pits into hell if you try
to push an enemy off the map the game
will inform you of the percentage chance
of that happening I can understand the
intent as successfully knocking an enemy
off the map counts as an instant
knockout to giving players a way of
cheesing through encounters would have
been a bit much Instead This one part of
the game acts as a last ditch effort
Lifeline if your back is against the
wall you might be able to clear the
field a bit with a few lucky shoves but
if you want a sure thing it's better to
strategize with the cards you've been
dealt and rely on your Heroes abilities
and Marvel's midnight Sons gives you a
solid lineup of Heroes right out of the
gate feeding you new faces and more
cards for the existing roster at regular
intervals your available strategies
evolve at a steady pace and no character
feels useless if you want to experiment
each character fulfills a distinct role
Captain Marvel's cards allow her to
build up Shields and taunt enemies with
powerful by attacks as an incredible
tank for instance Ghost Rider meanwhile
is a risky DPS with plenty of attacks
that damage both enemies and himself but
also has cards that allow him to
replenish Health from the enemies he
defeats missions have a variety of
structures too he may be tasked with
saving civilians while also holding off
enemy attacks or told you need to
destroy wave after wave of enemies that
are escalating in strength between the
different Mission types and numerous
characters all of whom possess dozens of
cards you can put in or leave out of
your deck upgrade or modify Marvel's
midnight Suns doesn't get repetitive
and that was something each character
can only bring a deck of 10 cards with
them into battle this keeps each
individual character deck small enough
to manage but large enough to diversify
with a few different strategies so you
can better adapt to the mission some
cards allow you to build heroism which
can be spent to play powerful heroic
cards cards can be upgraded to deal more
damage or modified with different
effects allowing you even more
customization one of the best secondary
effects a card can have is knockback
which allows you to push an enemy that
can be used to knock one enemy into
another damaging both or to send an
enemy into an environmental hazard like
an explosive container or fuse box
certain parts of every environment can
also be used by spending heroism a loose
rock can be thrown for example or a
hanging stack of crates dropped onto a
group of unsuspecting enemies there's a
great deal of choice in how you use your
cards and the battlefields to your
advantage with dozens of potential
combinations and configurations based on
who you're bringing to the mission and
what cards you have in your deck the
game does a great job ensuring you're
switching things up too Heroes can get
injured if they take too much damage on
a mission or suffer repeated wounds on
several missions in a row meaning it's
best to constantly rotate who you're
bringing into the next operation and
even if you don't and just want to
muscle through with who you like the
heroes you don't use as often never gets
left too far behind
there's another interesting wrinkle to
combat the Hunter's morality throughout
Marvel's midnight Suns the Hunter's
morality will be questioned and certain
cards in the Hunter's deck can cause it
to shift pushing them more towards light
or dark as you swing towards one or the
other you'll unlock new abilities and
cards associated with those different
moralities light cards are aimed at
healing and buffing allies while dark
cards all tend towards dealing a lot of
damage or twisting an enemy's mind
against them this gives you a tremendous
amount of agency over the Hunter's deck
which features more cards than any other
characters the hunter can be your
squad's best support character its most
dangerous damage dealer or some mixture
of both the choice is yours and it's
awesome to see how your decision to use
certain types of cards unlocks more
cards of that type similarly you'll more
quickly unlock new cards for whichever
Heroes you bring on missions to fight
alongside the hunter meaning you're
always earning cards for who you want to
play
what do you think between missions you
spend most of your time at the Abbey
dividing the experience of playing
Marvel's midnight Suns into an easy to
understand Loop of activities when
hanging out your regularly presented
with dialogue options for the hunter in
conversation how you speak to others
will determine how the Hunter's
relationship with them develops speaking
in a way a character finds favorable
will boost your friendship score with
that hero while saying something they
find disrespectful or foolhardy will
lower your score this means you have to
take the time to get to know a character
to best boost your relationship with
them this method of building friendships
with certain characters doesn't feel
artificial at all largely for how
Marvel's midnight Sons also ties the
Hunter's morality to dialogue of the
handful of dialogue options you have in
every conversation two or three are
typically associated with light or dark
allowing you to influence the Hunter's
morality outside of combat and in most
situations those lights and dark choices
are what defines whether you raise or
lower your friendship score with the
hero talking to your teammates in the
Abbey don't collectively view the world
in black and white so if you want to
raise your friendship with certain
characters that could mean picking a
dark morality option when you're
striving for a hunter that Embraces the
light and vice versa with friendship and
morality mixing together Marvel's
midnight Sons cleverly reflects how
relationships work in real life
encouraging you to find your people and
in doing so those characters moralities
rub off on the Hunter and inform the
type of hero and person they become it's
in these smaller interactions between
the Hunter and to the individual members
of their team that the game manages to
squeeze out those genuinely incredible
moments building up your friendship with
certain Heroes unlocks additional
cutscenes and conversations with them
many of which culminate in heartwarming
reveals or devastating discoveries magic
in particular is one of the best written
characters in Marvel's midnight sons and
her friendship Arc with the hunter which
sees the two Bond over their respective
struggles with their innate's darkness
is my favorite part of the game Laura
Bailey should be a applauded for how she
brings the troubled Russian mutant to
life and someone needs to make a magic
or New Mutants video game with her in
the lead role ASAP in the story it tells
Marvel's midnight Sons loses a bit of
its emotional punch given The Uncanny
stiffness of the faces of every
character model regardless of the
emotion of a scene every character's
facial expression is only a small
departure from their default eyes
slightly widen and surprise or curved
down with grief but the rest of the face
won't adjust to match for instance it's
often unsettling and can ruin what would
otherwise have been an especially
touching or emotional scene the vocal
performances from the incredible cast
save the story though especially for
those who bring to life the members of
the midnight Sun's team Michael J white
brings the badass attitude and hidden
warmth that we expect from blade for
example and Lyrica ocano has
effortlessly slid back into the role of
the magically gifted and Brilliant Nico
minoru a character she portrays in live
action on the TV show runaways The
Avengers and other non-magical hero side
of the equation feels a bit boring in
comparison and maybe that's an
intentional choice to further highlight
the mystical and demonic personalities
that make up the Midnight Sun side of
the game there are a bunch of nice
gameplay incentives for investing in
these friendships regardless of their
quality as the Hunter's friendship level
with a character reaches specific tears
you'll unlock passive perks for those
characters and upon reaching a
character's maximum friendship level you
unlock the ability to earn a unique
legendary card for that hero each one is
incredibly powerful sparing you to take
the time to befriend Your Heroes and
unlock more fun goodies to play around
with and incorporate into your strategy
magic healing there is a lot to love
about Marvel's midnight Suns the combat
offers a rewardingly tactical experience
with a deck building card system
ensuring that Randomness challenges the
player not frustrates them plus the
mission variety and cast of diverse
playable characters keep combat fresh
across dozens of hours but I most
enjoyed the role-playing elements and
giving the hunter a chance to connect
with the members of the midnight Suns
and Avengers forging friendships that
resulted in powerful abilities I could
take back to the combat side of the game
[Music]
for it